Zwei Sprechstunden.
Es ist mal wieder ein.
Hallo.
Und so, die erste Frage, die ich hier stellen möchte, ist, es gibt diese Idee, diese ganzen Buchstaben, die wir ins Internet schreiben, das ist einfach viel zu viel, um alles zu analysieren. Gibt es ein zu viel, wenn man Texte analysieren will?
Also es gibt natürlich Verarbeitungsgrenzen, aber von Interesse her eigentlich nicht. Also mein Traum ist natürlich, die Volltextdatenbank über alle jemals entstandenen Texte, das wäre natürlich großartig. Aber entscheidend ist ja, dass man aus diesen Texten Muster lernen lässt. Und je mehr Texte man hat, desto besser kristallisieren sich die Muster heraus. Und ja, auch desto besser kann man vielleicht auch sehen, was denn Abweichungen, einzelne Abweichungen von großen Musterclustern sind zum Beispiel.
Warte mal, also sagen, ich werfe erstmal den Text rein, ohne irgendwas dazu zu sagen und der Computer sucht erstmal raus, wie gleichen die sich. Kann man machen. Okay.
Aber es hängt natürlich immer von der Fragestellung ab. Also es hängt immer davon ab, was ich eigentlich wissen will, was ich dann auch sozusagen auf diese Texte loslasse. Es gibt natürlich so ein paar Standardverfahren, denke ich, die immer wieder vorkommen, also dass man irgendwie erst mal guckt, was sind denn wichtige Wörter in bestimmten Texten, was sind zum Beispiel auch dann Named Entities, also was sind irgendwie Orte, Organisationen, Personen, die in diesen Texten vorkommen. Das kann man alles automatisch natürlich erkennen lassen. Das ist zum Teil eben abhängig auch von den Sprachen. Also es gibt sozusagen sprachspezifische Algorithmen, die uns dabei helfen, diese Sachen zu erkennen. Und man kann dann eben weitergehen. Also je nachdem, was einen interessiert, kann man sagen, wir gucken uns eben Kollokationen an. Wir hatten schon davon gesprochen.
Nicht so schnell, nicht so schnell.
Typische Wortverbindungen.
Okay, also du hast ja auf dem Chaos-Kongress auch einen Vortrag gehalten über diese, sagen, Textverarbeitung. Und wenn man mit dir spricht, ist es also eine der Fingerübungen, scheinen ja zu sein, herauszufinden, wer überhaupt ein Text geschrieben hat.
Ja, also das ist ein Hobby. Nein, also wir hatten es vorher mit Multunimität, macht das Sinn, irgendwie mehrere Identitäten im Netz zu pflegen oder, also wenn man eben sich möglichst unsichtbar machen will. Also eine Gegenmaßnahme dagegen ist natürlich, dass man sagt, ja gut, wir versuchen jetzt Autoren zu identifizieren, indem wir ihre Sprache angucken und nach gemeinsamen Features suchen, die sozusagen alle ihre sprachliche Äußerungen in allen Kontexten haben und so die Anonymität aufzuheben oder zumindest zu lockern, um es mal so zu sagen. Ja, das macht man, indem man Texte nach wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr vielen Merkmalen beschreibt. Also das sind zum Teil Merkmalsvektoren, die haben 300, 400, 500 Merkmale drin. Also da sind auch so absurde Sachen drin, wie irgendwie, wie viele Wörter haben weniger als fünf Buchstaben beispielsweise. Aber auch andere Sachen, wie hoffe ich benutze jemand Konjunktiv, wie hoffe ich benutze jemand irgendwie Das-Sätze. Also eine ganz komplexe Beschreibung dieser Texte. Und dann kann man eben sagen, also Vektoren, die sich irgendwie stark ähneln, die Texte müssen dann von einem gleichen Autor sein. Das sind natürlich Zuschreibungen. Ich denke, ich bin ja Soziolinguist eigentlich vom Hause aus, also ich beschäftige mich irgendwie, wie Gesellschaft Sprache prägt und wie gesellschaftliche Praktiken Sprache prägen. Wir wissen natürlich, dass Textsorten einen ganz entscheidenden Einfluss haben, darauf wie Sprache aussieht. Also das heißt, wenn wir alle hier in diesem Studio ein Erpresserschreiben schreiben, dann ähneln sich das dieses Erpresserschreiben sprachlich wahrscheinlich eben, also die ähneln sich mehr, als wenn wir irgendwie unser Erpresserschreiben oder dein Erpresserschreiben mit deinen E-Mails vergleichen. Weil einfach die, wir orientieren uns immer an sozialen Mustern, wenn wir Texte schreiben und das macht die Sache halt ein bisschen schwierig. Auch wenn Informatiker uns manchmal Glauben machen wollen, das sei gar nicht so schwer und eigentlich sei das alles gleich, aber es ist nicht so ganz einfach, ja.
Okay, also das heißt, es geht oder es geht nicht?
Also es gibt natürlich experimentelle Settings, in denen das ganz gut funktioniert, aber ich weiß auch aus eigener Erfahrung und auch aus Leuten, die damit professionell arbeiten, dass es mit authentischen Falldaten sehr viel schlechter aussieht.
Also sagen, wenn man jetzt einen bestimmten Text nimmt und dann so denkt, okay, ich möchte jetzt wissen, wer den geschrieben hat, dann ist es schwierig, das wirklich mit Sicherheit zu sagen. Ja, okay, aber man kann es versuchen, kriegt eine Idee davon. Wie ist denn das, wenn man in einem eingeschränkten Gebiet arbeitet? Also sagen, wenn man nicht sagt, okay, irgendwie ganz Deutschland ein Text, wer war das? Aber wenn man sagt, irgendwie so Umfeld von 50 Leuten, ist es dann einfacher oder ist es dann schwieriger?
Grundsätzlich viel einfacher, also aber es hängt davon ab, wie stark sich die Leute unterscheiden in den Texten, ja. Also aber es ist auf jeden Fall sehr viel einfacher, ja. Und man würde es auch gar nicht machen, also ein Text ganz Deutschland, das wäre ziemlich sinnlos, weil man hat Hypothesen und die sollte man eher testen und nicht so völlig datengeleitet davon gehen.
Okay, da geht es dann eher schon darum, dass man sagt, okay wir haben schon einen bestimmten Verdacht, ob wir mal reingehen. Wie ist es denn mit dieser anderen Sache? Also weil wir wollen heute eher über diese ganz großen Sachen. Was kann man denn da in dieser Richtung machen? Das heißt sagen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie hier alle Daten, also Texte von allen Leuten, was kann man denn da rausfinden?
Ja, was willst du denn rausfinden?
Moment mal, so war das nicht geplant.
Ja, das ist die entscheidende Frage, die wir erstmal beantworten müssen.
Also ich kann es so persönlich sagen. Persönlich ist es so, ich twitter zum Beispiel und ich denke, dass ich sozusagen, also mir ist schon klar, dass wenn man meinen Twitter liest, dass man dann von einer Vorstellung davon bekommt, wer ich bin, weil das natürlich in einer gewissen Art und Weise, auch wenn ich nicht über alles twittere, was mich bewegt oder was mein Leben ausmacht, lernt man da doch, wie ich zum Beispiel, usw. usf. Trotzdem denke ich, ich bin jetzt nicht unbedingt die Person, also die da auf Twitter ist. Das ist halt die Frage. Also wenn ich so jetzt die Twitter, also alle Tweets von einer einzelnen Person, von jemanden, mit dem ich mich analysiere, weiß ich dann zum Beispiel sowas wie, wie er drauf ist? Also sag ich jetzt mal ganz...
Wenn du es wissen willst, wie er drauf ist, dann kannst du entsprechende Algorithmen schaffen. Also ich, ich, Entschuldigung, dass ich dir jetzt so ausweiche, aber ich finde, du, also die Frage geht meiner Meinung nach in die falsche Richtung, weil Daten werden immer mit einem bestimmten Ziel analysiert. Ja und je nach dem Ziel baue ich mir meinen, meinen Untersuchungsdesign oder irgendwie meine Algorithmen und die kann ich besser und schlechter bauen. Und ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht so, also wenn du jetzt sagst, wir sollen deinen Charakter analysieren aufgrund deiner Twitter-Daten. Okay, dann bauen wir uns ein Modell und sagen, okay dein Charakter hat, also oder sozusagen aus der Psychologie nehmen wir irgendwie, Charakter hat irgendwie so und so viele Dimensionen, fünf Dimensionen, die Big Five. Und dann gucken wir, wie wir die eben sprachlich irgendwie abbilden können. Dann formulieren vielleicht Hypothesen, dass sich Emotionalität in bestimmten Wörtern und Wortverbindungen zeigt und dass wir die, wenn wir die besonders häufig finden, dann schreiben wir die eben zu, dass du ein emotionaler Mensch bist. So würden wir vielleicht vorgehen. Aber so ganz ohne Wissen baut keiner solche Systeme und auch nicht ganz ohne so ein konkretes Analyseziel. Und in dieses Analyseziel und in diese Konzepte geht eben ganz viel Weltwissen ein. Und ganz viele auch Machtpositionen. Also was ein Geheimdienst denkt, was ein Terrorist ist oder sowas, das definiert eben er. Und darüber gibt es keinen gesellschaftlichen Diskurs und sowas, sondern das ist eine Definition, die dort gemacht wird und dann, ja.
Also vielleicht hilft es mal ein Beispiel anzugucken für real existierende Systeme, die tatsächlich automatisiert Texte auswerten und auf der Basis davon Entscheidungen zu treffen. Und zwar an der Börse gibt es ja Pflichtinformationen, die die notierten Unternehmen veröffentlichen müssen. Und diese werden automatisiert ausgewertet. Und auf Grundlage dieser Informationen werden Kauf- und Verkaufsentscheidungen getroffen. Das heißt, was man hat, was reinkommt, sind diese sogenannten Ad-hoc-Meldungen, die den Vorteil haben, dass sie eine sehr, sehr formale, kodifizierte Sprache haben. Also hast du keine große Variationsbreite, sondern das sind alles Standardsätze, die ähnliche Formulierungen haben, bestimmte Schlüsselwörter, die immer gleich funktionieren. Auf der anderen Seite musst du nun eine sehr einfache Entscheidung treffen, nämlich kaufen oder verkaufen. Und das funktioniert tatsächlich, das ist im Einsatz. Und wenn so eine Ad-hoc-Meldung draußen ist, innerhalb von Millisekunden sind die Algorithment-Trading-Systeme dabei und kaufen und verkaufen die Aktien auf Grundlage dieser Informationen.
Haben Sie schon jemanden reich gemacht? Außer demjenigen, der die Software geschrieben hat?
Na, derjenige, der die Software schreibt, das sind in der Regel die großen Aktienhäuser. Also tatsächlich werden mittlerweile 70 Prozent des gesamten Handels automatisiert abgewickelt. Das sind also nicht nur diese Ad-hoc-Analysesysteme. Da gab es einen ganz großartigen Fall. Da wurde nämlich, Twitter wird übrigens auch ausgewertet. Also das sind die Leute, die sich mal eben die paar hundert Rechner hinstellen, um Twitter in Echtzeit auszuwerten. Da wurde ein Twitter-Account übernommen von irgendeinem Hacker, irgendwas Großes, ich glaube irgendeine Nachrichtenmagazine, CNN oder sowas und zwei, drei falsche Informationen getwittert und plötzlich haben die angefangen, Aktien zu kaufen, verkaufen automatisiert. Also in den Stellen geht das dann halt schief. Aber tatsächlich verdienen die echten Haufen Geld und dominieren mittlerweile das Börsengeschäft mit solchen automatisierten Systemen.
Wow, ich glaube, die spannende Frage wäre nicht, wer damit reich geworden ist, sondern wie viel Börsencrest dadurch schon verunstaltet wurden.
Dazu machen wir mal eine ganz eigene Frage, das ist ein hochspannendes Thema.
Okay, über sekundlichen Börsenhandel. Joachim, zurück zu dir. Möglicherweise stelle ich die falschen Fragen, weil du, ich kenne dich sozusagen, man kennt dich aus dem Chaos-Umfeld, weil du halt Vorträge über diese Textanalyse-Möglichkeiten hältst und da erklärst, was geht. Was geht denn? Du hast ja auch ein Beispiel mitgebracht. Also wovor, oder andersrum, wovor muss man sich denn fürchten bei dieser Überwachung? Oder was wird da versucht?
Vor den Überwachern muss man sich fürchten. Warum muss man sich fürchten? Ich finde, wir sollten vielleicht erst mal so aufbauen, was man sich alles angucken kann in Texten. Also wir haben ja so irgendwelche Terme oder Keywords, wir haben vielleicht auch Named Entities. Dann machen wir Kollokationen, wir gucken uns an, was sind typische Wortverbindungen.
Okay, warte, warte, warte. Also Named Entities, das heißt sozusagen, es ist kein Problem, dass ich einem Computer beibringe zu sagen, okay, das und das sind Namen, damit sind Personen gemeint. Oder Orte oder Markennamen oder was auch immer man sich da ausdenkt. Das sind also das, wenn du Named Entity sagst, dann hat man irgendeine Kategorie gefunden, das und das sind so. Okay, Kollokationen, noch mal ein spannendes, genauer kleines, also Worte, die zusammen auftreten.
Ja, also nicht Worte, die zufällig zusammen auftreten, sondern sogar Worte, die eben überzufällig häufig zusammen auftreten. Also wo man eben sagen kann, wenn man so denkt, die werden zufällig verteilt, dann könnte man eine bestimmte Frequenz annehmen, aber die treten eben sehr viel häufiger auf, als diese zufällige Verteilung uns nahelegen würde. Also das heißt, es sind typische Wortverbindungen. Und du hast gesagt, ich hab was vorbereitet. Also wir haben gerade vor der Sendung ein bisschen rumgerechnet. Und da konnten wir zum Beispiel feststellen, Islambrüderschaft haben wir uns angeguckt, den deutschen Blog. Und international ist zum Beispiel dort, sind Kollokationen sind israelisch, Verfolgung, Gemeinschaft, Konferenz, Regierung und so weiter. Bei der RAF, die wir uns auch angeguckt haben, da ist es imperialistisch, Kampf, Klassenkrieg, Westeuropa. Und bei Angela Merkel ist es Finanzkrise, Staat und Gemeinschaft bindend. Und man kann sozusagen, wenn man all diese Kollokationen zusammen nimmt, kann man Profile erstellen. Also das heißt, man kann Profile erstellen, welche typischen Wortverbindungen ein Mensch hat. Du zum Beispiel in deinen Moderationen, ich in meinen Aufsätzen, der Andi in seinen Radio-Moderationen und Blogbeiträgen. Und auf die Weise kann man natürlich erstens Themen identifizieren. Man kann aber auch gegebenenfalls auch, je nachdem um welche Wortverbindungen es sich handelt, welche man da anschaut, kann man auch Autorinnen und Autoren identifizieren damit.
Also das ist dann aber quasi so eine Art, also man macht das einmal und dann weiß man etwas und dann kann man in Zukunft sagen, gucken wo das noch auftaucht.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit daran zu gehen, zu sagen okay, wir wissen die RAF war Terroristen und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken, gibt es denn heute auch solche Leute wie die RAF, die genauso solche Theorien vertreten und die wahrscheinlich mit dem ähnlichen Überzeugungsgrad codieren, weil wir vielleicht dann denken, das sind vielleicht potenzielle Gefährder und dann würde man eben tatsächlich von den Texten der RAF lernen, Muster lernen und würde gucken, wo findet man die denn, nicht auf Twitter, aber irgendwo.
Das ist auch eine spannende Frage. Wie lange muss denn so ein Text sein, damit ich ihn sinnvoll mit anderen Sachen vergleichen kann? Gibt es dann eine gewisse Länge?
Ja, damit man sinnvoll Kolokationen berechnen kann, braucht es schon ein bisschen mehr Text, finde ich.
Und wenn man das Ergebnis einmal hat, reichen dann auch sozusagen?
Dann reichen auch wenige.
Dann reichen auch wenige, okay. Also man braucht einmal sozusagen viel, um anzufangen, aber dann kann man so, okay. Was ich mich jetzt immer frage, ist, also das klingt für mich alles so, ich kann zwar Programme schreiben, die sind auch beliebig komplex, aber die sind letztlich auch nicht mehr. Das sind halt nur komplexe Wörterbücher. Oder kann man tatsächlich?
Das ist natürlich mehr als Wörterbücher, ja. Also eben, wir können Themen lernen, also mit Topic Modeling können wir bestimmte Themenkombinationen feststellen. Wir können gucken, wir hängen Themen zusammen. Wir werden die Inteksen verknüpft. Also man kann schon eine ganze Menge mehr machen als sozusagen ein reines Wörterbuch haben. Also wir können zum Beispiel, wenn wir uns jetzt dann doch RAV-Texte angucken, stellen wir zum Beispiel fest, dass irgendwie, ich hab das mal durchgerechnet, gefangene Forderung, Freilassung, Zusammenlegung, Freiheit, Isolation, Hungerstreik, Kollektiv und so weiter bilden ein Thema. Also das heißt, der Algorithmus stellt fest, dass in Texten diese Wörter, wenn man sie gewichtet hat, signifikant häufig zusammen auftreten und deswegen ein Thema ausmachen müssen. Und dieses Thema kann man in vielen Texten wiederum feststellen. Und also man kann wirklich schon relativ viel machen, man kann eben, wie wir ganz am Anfang gehört haben, man kann die Haltung zu diesen Themen messen. Aber wie ich schon versucht habe zu erklären, Texte haben keine so eindeutig festgelegte Bedeutung. Sie haben sie nie. Also weil sie sind, also schon der Autor, die Autorin gibt dem Text keine eindeutige Bedeutung, hat beim Widerlesen jeder den Text immer wieder anders. Und was die Leserinnen und Leser betrifft sowieso und all diesen Dingen wird die computergesteuerte Analyse natürlich nicht vollständig gerecht und auch überhaupt nicht gerecht eigentlich, denn wir haben eigentlich den Anspruch, dass wenn wir den Text zweimal mit dem gleichen Algorithmus analysieren, dass es auch das gleiche herauskommt.
Das hätte ich jetzt erwartet, ja.
Aber wenn wir zweimal den Text lesen, kommt zweimal was anderes raus.
Also für die Schülerinnen und Schülern und Zuhörern, wenn ihr im Deutschunterricht gefragt werdet, was wollte der Autor uns damit sagen, ist die einzige zulässige Antwort, das weiß ich auch nicht. Ich kann nur analysieren, was er geschrieben hat.
So, und dann sagen, wenn ich das zweimal mache, kommt möglicherweise ein Unterschied raus, bei Computer kommt immer dasselbe raus und das ist eigentlich der Teil des Problems.
Wahrscheinlich nochmal was drittes unterschiedliches, das ist das Teil des Problems, ja.
Aber das kommt dann immer wieder raus.
Genau, da sind wir jetzt bei der Kommunikationstheorie, dass Kommunikation zwingt, ein Sender und ein Empfänger und ein Kanal dazwischen voraussetzt und es nicht unbedingt gegeben ist, dass irgendwie Sender und Empfänger dieselbe Kodierung verwenden.
Ja, aber liebe Leute, wenn man das jetzt als gegebenenhin mir kann man sagen, können wir diesen ganzen Quatsch auch gleich sparen. Warum macht man es denn?
Ja, es geht an der Stelle wirklich um banalere Fragestellungen, um diese Topic Modeling zurückzukommen. Es geht wirklich darum, ein sogenanntes Modell zu schaffen, mit dem ich eine Frage beantworten kann. Die Fragen sind relativ einfach. Die Fragen sind, ist dieses Dokument gefährlich für mich oder nicht? Und das kann ich jetzt eben auf genau meine Gefahr hintrainieren. Und das ist mir darum sehr, sehr schwer abhängig von, wer du bist und was du wissen willst. Ist es gefährlich für meinen Staat? Ist es gefährlich für meine Firma, für meine Familie? Das sind am Ende des Tages wirklich eine Ja- oder Nein-Frage. Und diese Ja- oder Nein-Frage wird mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit beantwortet. Und wenn diese Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch genug ist, dann sollte sich jemand das wirklich mal angucken. Und darum geht es an einem Tag.
Das ist wie bei Casablanca, da sagt dann am Ende einer, round up the usual suspects. Und einer von den Szenen ist es dann, wo der Algorithmus gesagt hat, irgendwie da guckt er mal genauer hin. Oder zumindest ist es die Vorstellung, die da in den Köpfen existiert.
Aber also wenn man euch so hört, dann würden jetzt die Leute, die sagen, ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen, automatisch Recht bekommen. Weil tatsächlich ist es ja so, wenn sie sozusagen, wenn sie nichts Böses gemacht haben, dann tauchen sie sowieso nicht auf in der verdächtigen Gruppe. Und selbst wenn sie auftauchen, ist es ja nicht so schlimm, weil sie werden dann ja nochmal von den Menschen kontrolliert und dann sozusagen wieder aussortiert, weil sie da doch nicht verdächtigt waren. Also ist das mit Überwachung eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm?
Na genau, das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Also gerade die Tatsache, dass diese Auswertung nicht so verlässlich funktioniert, heißt, dass es Faults Positives gibt. Also dass Leute betroffen sind, die tatsächlich, also nichts zu verbergen. Also wer hat schon nichts zu verbergen? Also zumindest der Mannung ist, dass es nicht nichts zu Schulden hat kommen lassen, wo dann plötzlich Drohnen rumfliegen und einen erschießen könnten. Trotzdem Opfer davon werden, dass eine Drohne kommt und einen erschießt und dass in Probleme kommen. Also Brasil, die wunderschöne, da wird der Buchstabe verwechselt, dann lautet der Haftbefehl auf den Falschen und dann landet er im Knast. Also genau das ist die Folge davon, dass solche Analysen eben nie perfekt sein können.
Und das muss man hinzufügen, wir wissen nicht, was uns zugeschrieben wird. Also wir wissen nicht, wonach gesucht wird, weil das sich eben im Raum abspielt, der sozusagen zur Schutzlogik dazugehört. Die Logik der Überwachung ist etwas, das geheim bleiben muss, weil dann funktioniert sie nämlich nicht mehr, wenn sie öffentlich würde.
Du kannst dich nicht mal unauffällig verhalten, weil du weißt nicht, was unauffällig ist.
Richtig. Jetzt komme ich da nicht mehr hinterher. Also weil ihr habt ja gerade erklärt, es gibt diese Systeme, aber die funktionieren nicht so richtig zuverlässig. Das heißt ja eigentlich, die Systeme sind egal und dann habt ihr jetzt gesagt, man kann sich aber nicht vor den Systemen schützen, weil man weiß nicht, wie sie funktionieren.
Wir haben nicht gesagt, dass es egal ist.
Weil sie sind ja nicht konsequenzlos. Da laufen ja die Jungs mit dem Maschinengewehr los, je nachdem, was diese Systeme gesagt haben. Das ist doch der Punkt dabei. Dass sie nicht hundertprozentig funktionieren, ist das Problem. Das ist nämlich genau das Problem, dass halt die Jungs mit dem Maschinengewehren möglicherweise zu den Falschen kommen, nämlich zu dir, weil du aus Versehen mit demselben Muster telefoniert hast, wie die Terroristen auch.
Also ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass die Leute mit dem Maschinengewehren kommen. Davon abgesehen, es wäre schlimm, wenn diese Systeme hundertprozentig funktionieren würden. Nee, aber die Frage, die Simon gestellt hat, ist, wer stellt denn die Fragen, mit welchen Interessen? Und das sind eben vielleicht nicht die Interessen, die man als Bürger oder Bürgerin hat. Und wir dürfen nicht die Fragen mitstellen. Wir wissen gar nicht, was die Fragen sind. Und das macht das Ganze zum Problem.
Ich glaube auch, wenn man mal ein anderes Beispiel nimmt, das nicht gerade so eine großräumige Polizeieüberwachung oder so nimmt, kann man die ganze Sache auch noch weiter treiben. Also was ich so bei der Recherche gefunden habe, war eine ganz gruselige Firma von meiner Seite aus Aachen, die nennt sich PsiWare, was auch schon mal gut klingt, so wie SpyWare. Und die haben irgendwie eine Software gemacht für Text oder auch Sprachanalyse, die sie verkaufen an Unternehmen, die Bewerber einstellen wollen, an Krankenkassen und an Polizei. Das heißt, sie sagen zum Beispiel den Unternehmen, die die Bewerberauswahl machen wollen, wir können ihnen dabei helfen, Bewerber herauszufinden, die besonders leistungsfähig sind und die besonders gut für ihr Unternehmen geeignet sind. Das machen sie eben, indem sie einfach diese Software über Bewerbungsunterlagen darüber laufen lassen und dann einfach auch die raussortieren, die wahrscheinlich nicht den Anforderungen gerecht werden. Oder bei dieser Krankenkassengeschichte bieten sie eine Telefon-Hotline an, da kann der Mensch dann anrufen und prüfen lassen, ob er psychisch gestört ist. Das heißt, sie sagen, psychisch gestört oder verängstigte Menschen haben eine bestimmte Wortwahl und in dem Fall auch noch eine bestimmte Sprachfrequenz oder ein bestimmtes Sprachverhalten. Und dann können wir eben sagen, dieser Mensch hat wahrscheinlich irgendeine psychische Auffälligkeit. Und das ist halt der Bobett, wo man richtig das Gruseln bekommt. Weil wenn man das, also wenn man so analysiert wird, ohne dass man das weiß, dann kann es ja noch ganz andere Konsequenzen haben. Dass dann vielleicht die Krankenkasse, bei der man nur anrufen will, um einzutreten, dass sie dann plötzlich sagt, nee, wollen wir nicht, weil sie sind ja vielleicht irgendwie psychisch gestört. Und wenn man das nicht mal mitkriegt, dann wird das Ganze ganz absurd. Und die meinen eben auch, sie verkaufen diese Systeme an Versicherungen, um dann eben eine Vorauswahl zu treffen, wer die Versicherung betrügen will. Das heißt, die Versicherung sagt dann aufgrund von einem Gespräch, dass man am Telefon mit ihnen geführt hat, wo man vielleicht ein bisschen nervös war oder ein bisschen aufgeregt, weil gerade das Haus abgebrannt ist. Nee, sie sind auffällig. Das ist wahrscheinlich Versicherungsbetrug. Das sind einfach so Anwendungsfälle, mit denen rechnet man nicht. Die sind jetzt nicht die große Überwachung, wo denn jemand mit dem Maschinengewehr kommt, sondern eine sehr alltägliche Überwachung. Und die Firma hat eben auch gewisse Referenzen und sagt eben ja, zu unseren Kunden gehören zum Beispiel die Actimonda Krankenkasse und eben auch die Polizei Nordrhein-Westfalen. Das heißt, man kann sich so ein bisschen ausmalen, wo das vielleicht noch überall eingesetzt werden könnte.
Das zeigt ja eigentlich auch, dass die Kritik, die Algorithmen funktionieren nicht richtig, eigentlich nicht unser Ziel sein kann. Weil da könnte man immer noch sagen, machen wir die doch besser.
Das ist auch das, was ich jetzt gerade sozusagen im Moment mitnehme.
Ja, also ich finde eben das Argument viel besser, dass wir darüber diskutieren müssen, welche Fragen gestellt werden an diese Software, welche legitim sind, welche wir zulassen wollen als Gesellschaft und welche eben auch nicht. Das finde ich eigentlich die wichtigere Frage. Also was auf unsere Daten, wie die befragt werden dürfen, finde ich eigentlich irgendwie die wichtigere Frage.
Ich finde das auch gleich eine ganz gute Stelle, um mal zu erwähnen, dass es ja nicht nur um den Inhalt der Kommunikation geht, sondern dass das, was allgemein Metadaten genannt wird, also das, wo uns versucht wird, zu beruhigen, wir speichern ja nur die Metadaten in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, dass das auch sehr, sehr viel aussagt. Das ist also nicht notwendigerweise nur um die Analyse der Texte geht, die man schreibt und dem, was man sagt, sondern auch das, wann man mit wem kommuniziert, schon sehr, sehr viel Aussagekraft hat, wo man sich befindet und so weiter und so fort. Und auch diese Information wird automatisiert ausgewertet. Also auch das kann man zum Beispiel alle Telefongespräche nehmen. Wer hat wen angerufen? Inhalte komplett wegwerfen, weil das ist ja vielleicht dann doch zu viel. Aber die paar hundert Millionen Telefongespräche, die am Tag geführt werden in Deutschland, die bekommt man damit noch in Griff mit dieser Technik, die wir gehört haben, die nicht allzu teuer ist. Und kann dann da zum Beispiel Cluster-Analysen fahren. Also was sind denn Gruppen von Menschen, die irgendwie miteinander zusammenhängen? Und dann kann man sagen, wir wissen, der ist ein Terrorist. Was sind denn so Gruppen, in denen er sich bewegt und dann tauchen plötzlich so 20, 30, 50 Blasen von Leuten auf, die man dann vielleicht mal näher untersuchen kann, wo man dann so eine V-Leute reinschickt und so weiter und so fort. Also auch das ist Resultat von solchen Auswertungen. Auch das ist quasi Massenüberwachung.
Das finde ich eine sehr, sehr, sehr interessante Fragestellung. Weil in dem Moment, wo wir diese Cluster bilden und diesen Clustern auch bestimmte Gruppen zuordnen können, fangen wir an, Leute noch mehr zu überwachen, noch detaillierter Informationen zu sammeln von diesen Menschen, die gar nichts Unrechtes getan haben an der Stelle. Und allein schon die Zuordnung dieses Clusters reicht aus, um diesen Verdacht herzustellen. Das ist die ganz interessante Fragestellung hier, finde ich.
Also solche Algorithmen werden ja auch eingesetzt, zum Beispiel in Banken, um Kredite zu vergeben. Ja, das haben sie mir im Studium mal erzählt, wie man als kleines mittelständisches Unternehmen bei seiner Bank noch einen Kredit bekommt, zufällig von den Menschen, der für die Sparkasse, die Software geschrieben hat, die diese Entscheidung trifft. Also wie die Bilanz ausgewertet wird. Die haben damals noch sehr, sehr viel Wert darauf gelegt, dass sie nur solche Algorithmen verwenden, die auch nachvollziehbar sind. Also in dem Fall waren es sogenannte Entscheidungsbäume. Das heißt, irgendwie wir sehen, irgendwie statistisch gesehen, Leute unter 20 haben größeres Kreditrisiko als Leute über 30. Und du bist unter 20, deswegen kriegst du keinen Kredit. Oder du bist zwar über 30, aber du hast irgendwie ständig dein Konto überzogen, also kriegst du keinen Kredit. Eine nachvollziehbare Argumentation, wo dann hinterher der Sachbeabteil auch noch erklärt, ja, hören sie mal her, gucken sie sich ihre Kreditgeschichte an, ist leider schwierig. Es gibt aber viele Algorithmen, da weiß man hinterher gar nicht mehr, warum etwas passiert ist. Die liefern diese Informationen des Warum nicht mehr mit, die sagen nur noch der da. Die zeigen mit dem Finger auf ein Ergebnis und sagen, der da ist verdächtig. Und warum ist der verdächtig? Sagt er dir irgendwie, na ja, ich hab hier eine riesengroße Matrix mit lauter Zahlen und da ist es irgendwie rausgefallen, dass er verdächtig ist. Das korreliert mit allen anderen, die verdächtig sind in diesem Land.
Also das ist das eigentliche Problem, sagen an der Schleppnetzdatenüberwachung, dass man sagt, man hat eben ganz, ganz viele Daten, die wirft man rein und dann lässt man sozusagen Systeme, die nicht ganz korrekt arbeiten, da drüber laufen und die sagen dann, okay, von dir ausgedachten Merkmalen 1, 2 und 3 sind, diese Leute verdächtig.
Genau, auch nicht mehr nachvollziehbar, wie das eigentlich zustande gekommen ist, also nicht mehr begründbar.
Gleichzeitig hatten wir jetzt das Schufa-Urteil und Schufa ist natürlich genauso eine transparente Organisation, die Daten sammelt und daraufhin Scores erstellt über die Kreditwürdigkeit von Personen und diese Scores machen, also was sie machen, sind natürlich Zuschreibungen auf Menschen. Also wenn man in einem bestimmten Viertel wohnt, ist das ein Malus oder ein Bonus, je nachdem wie solvent die Mitbewohner in diesem Viertel sind und das sind ja Dinge, die haben mit einem selber ja eigentlich gar nichts zu tun im Sinne von der eigenen Individualität oder der eigene Lebensgeschichte, sondern das ist einfach aggregierte Daten, die auf einen selber angewendet werden, ohne dass man sich dagegen wehren könnte und ich finde da sind wir in einem Bereich, der also höchst problematisch ist.
Also das heißt, wenn jemand das Argument sagt, ich habe doch nicht zu verbergen, ist es eigentlich gar kein Argument gegen Überwachung, weil es tatsächlich in den meisten Fällen gar nicht darum geht, jetzt schon ganz konkret in den Einzelnen irgendwas zuzuhängen, sondern der macht sich dadurch, dass er überwacht wird, ist er sozusagen Teil einer, ich sage jetzt mal Statistik, die erstellt wird und damit fällt er dann möglicherweise irgendwo rein, ohne genau zu wissen warum. Das ist sozusagen das Problem an dieser Stelle. Gut, also was haben wir gelernt? Es geht ganz schön viel, aber es arbeitet unkonkret und das Problem ist, dass wir gar nicht genau wissen, was hinter den Kulissen alles passiert und trotzdem möglicherweise deswegen dran sind. Was die Konsequenzen aussehen können, das klären wir gleich. Vorher gibt es erst noch mal die Nachrichten hier im Chaosradio im Blumen und danach machen wir noch eine letzte halbe Stunde weiter.
Neumann. Unter den ganz großen Shooting Stars ist John Newman noch relativ neu.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Immer gute neue Musik.
Um kurz nach halb zwölf.
Formel 1 Rekordweltmeister Michael Schumacher wird aus dem künstlichen Koma geholt. Schumachers Managerin hat heute bestätigt, dass die Narkosemittel jetzt nach und nach reduziert werden. Der Aufwachprozess kann aber sehr lange dauern. Schumacher war kurz vor dem Jahreswechsel beim Skifahren verunglückt. Wegen seiner schweren Hirnverletzungen hatten die Ärzte ihnen ein künstliches Koma versetzt. Bundeswirtschaftsminister Gabriel will die Energiewende nicht alleine gestalten. Der SPD-Politiker hat gesagt, dass er mit den Bundesländern zusammenarbeiten will. Bei der Energiewende gibt es Streit darüber, wie der Umstieg von Atom- und Kohlestrom am besten funktionieren könnte. Gabriel will die Förderung von Windkraftanlagen an Land kürzen und das kritisieren mehrere Bundesländer. Berlin hat das Studium für angehende Lehrer umgemodelt. In Zukunft wird es statt vier nur noch drei Studiengänge geben. Einen für Grundschulen, einen für Sekundarschulen und Gymnasien, sowie einen für berufliche Schulen. Wer Sonderschullehrer werden will, muss zusätzlich das Fachsonderpädagogik belegen. Ein Praxissemester wird eingeführt und das Referendariat wird für alle Lehrämter anderthalb Jahre dauern.
Sport.
Die Basketballer von Alba Berlin haben das Eurocup-Spiel in der Ukraine gewonnen. Bei Jushner gab es ein 68 zu 65 Sieg nach Verlängerung. Das Spiel musste um einen Tag verschoben werden, weil die Berliner bei ihrer Anreise im Schneesturm stecken geblieben waren. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin immer noch überall minus 4, nur Spandau minus 3 Grad, Cottbus und Angermünde minus 5, Potsdam und Falkensee minus 4 Grad. Nachts kann es vereinzelt noch ein bisschen schneien, es kann aber auch anderseits ganz kurzzeitig Sternen klar werden bei Tiefstwerten um minus 8 Grad. Morgen dann viele Wolken, kaum noch Schnee und vor allen Dingen Tauwetter bei Plusgraden plus 5 Grad maximal. Dort verkehrt Berlin 100, der Stadtring in beiden Richtungen immer noch abschnittsweise stockender Verkehr. Mitte die Wilhelmstraße ist zwischen Leipziger Straße und Bärenstraße in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, da ist ein Kran im Einsatz. Brandenburg A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck Spreeau. Zwischen Königswusterhausen und Niederlehme steht ein kaputter Laster. A12 Frankfurt Oder Richtung Berlin, zwischen Grenzübergang Frankfurt Oder und Frankfurt Oder Süd, da hat es auf der linken Spur gekracht. Und noch zur S-Bahn, die S2. Bis Betriebsschluss wird der Abschnitt zwischen Blankenfelde und Lichtenrade unterbrochen. Stattdessen fahrende Busse zwischen Lichtenrade und Marienfelde besteht Pendelverkehr im 20-Minuten-Takt. Worum er sagt, gute Fakt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von letzter Nacht verpasst habt oder ihn einfach nochmal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach nochmal. So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream, Musikstream auf fritz.de.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon mit Marcus Richter und natürlich vielen Besuchern, die vom Chaos Computer Club und angeschlossenen Senderanstalten könnte man beinahe sagen kommen. Na ja, Andreas Bogk ist zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club. Hallo, guten Tag. Joachim Scharloth, hallo, guten Tag. Simon Willnauer, hallo, guten Tag. Und Anna Biselli, hallo, guten Abend. War zumindest vorhin noch da und jetzt, ach hier vielleicht, hallo. Ah, ist immer noch da. War der falsche Regler offen. Chaos Radio, macht seinem Namen alle Ehre. Wir reden heute über Datenanalyse, also was eigentlich passiert mit den ganzen Daten, die die Geheimdienste möglicherweise, man weiß es ja nicht ganz genau, also die deutschen Geheimdienstmitarbeiter sind sich ja auch gar nicht so sicher, dass das wirklich passiert. Also die ganzen Daten, die über uns angelegt worden sind, wie man die analysieren kann. Und es sind zwei Sachen rausgekommen, also A, es geht tatsächlich, also man kann das auch mit viel Geld, also mit mehr Geld als wir wahrscheinlich alle verdienen, aber es geht schon irgendwie einzurichten. Und dann ist das Problem, wie ich jetzt selber gelernt habe, nicht so sehr, dass da konkret Dinge über eine einzelne Person rausgefunden werden, sondern dass da Algorithmen verwendet werden. Und erbrecht mich jetzt bitte anwesende Leute, wenn ich das falsch zusammenfasse. Es gibt also Algorithmen, die laufen über diese gesammelten Daten drüber und tun dann Leute zusammen in eine Gruppe. Und diese Gruppe wird dann möglicherweise verdächtigt. Niemand weiß so genau, was da passiert, weil die Algorithmen mittlerweile so komplex sind oder auch nicht so genau sein können, dass das so eigentlich Magie und Voodoo gleicht.
Ja und nein.
Also was ich verstanden habe ist, die Algorithmen können Dinge rausfinden. Diese Dinge sind aber nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Trotzdem werden sie benutzt, um Leuten Eigenschaften zuzuschreiben, die sie möglicherweise gar nicht haben, z.B. du bist ein Terrorist.
Genau, genau, so ist das glaube ich schon präziser formuliert. Natürlich ist das auch für das Individuum ein Problem, diese Massenüberwachung, weil wenn alle überwacht werden, heißt das, dass auch gegen dich etwas gefunden werden kann, wenn sie dich auf dem Kieke haben. Also wenn erstmal rausgekommen ist, du bist Terrorist, dann gibt es dann natürlich unglaubliche Mengen von Daten, die da rumliegen, um zu gucken, wie schlimm du wirklich bist und wie böse du wirklich bist. Und das ist im Zweifelsfall, keine Ahnung, wenn du nicht Terrorist bist, sondern sagen wir, der politische Gegner des gerade herrschenden Diktators, auch ein Problem für dich. Also das ist dann nichts mehr, wo die Algorithmen das Problem sind, sondern wo die Überwachung das Problem ist.
Also das System würde doch nie jemand missbrauchen.
Na natürlich nicht.
Okay, wir haben noch einen Anrufer tatsächlich, das ist der Mario. Und er hat, Achtung, die Sendung hat internationale Resonanz gefunden. Mario ruft aus den USA an.
Warum rufst du an? Ja, ich würde gerne wissen, ob diese Programme nur eine Quelle überwachen, zum Beispiel SMS oder Twitter oder können diese Programme auch feststellen, dass ich mehrere Chats benutze oder von mehreren Accounts schreibe?
Also wir hatten die Frage sozusagen zu Teilen schon beantwortet. Es lässt sich sozusagen erstmal nicht vor Ort umansch darstellen, aber man kann sozusagen Autoren schafft von Texten tatsächlich versuchen, mehr festzustellen.
Moment, das ist ja nicht das einzige, worüber man Analysen machen kann, also über diese Autoren schafft, sondern auch so über sowas wie Gleichzeitigkeit. Es gibt bei der NSA eine Fraktion, die, wie mein Insider berichtet, die Pokémon-Fraktion genannt wird. Sammeln sie alle, also die wollen einfach alle Daten, alles was anfällt, wollen die haben. Und das heißt natürlich nicht nur SMS, sondern auch alle Chat-Systeme, an die sie ihre Finger kriegen. Und das heißt natürlich insbesondere solche Chat-Systeme, an die einfach ranzukommen sind, weil sie alle über einen zentralen Server laufen, der auch noch bei amerikanischen Firmen steht. Also wenn du bei Yahoo-Chattest oder sowas, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass alles mitgeschnitten wird. Und die Analysen darüber, welche Accounts möglicherweise dieselbe Person sind, laufen dann zum Beispiel über zeitliche Korrelationen. Irgendwie, wann ist der Account online gegangen, wann ist er wieder offline gegangen? Gibt es möglicherweise Überschneidungen in den Leuten, die mit ihnen reden? Und da fallen relativ schnell die zusammengehörigen Accounts raus. Also wenn man sich guckt, die, die sich immer gleichzeitig einloggen, die sich gleichzeitig ausloggen. Und genau solche Suchen sind auch etwas, was sich relativ leicht darstellen lässt. Also wenn wir 100 Milliarden Log-in-Ereignisse in der großen Datenbank haben, zu sagen, finde mal alle raus, die innerhalb von fünf Sekunden passieren. Und dann die sortiert nach der Häufigkeit von Pärchen. Das ist eine typische Suchanfrage, die so ein System darstellen kann. Und da fällt dann raus, wie loggt sich immer da ein mit demselben System. Und deswegen gehören die Accounts zusammen.
Mario, beantwortet das deine Frage?
Eigentlich läuft so etwas anderes hinaus. Wenn ich nun einen bestimmten Chat benutze für Spiele, sind ja, keine Ahnung, Kriegsspiele oder was auch immer so im Internet zu spielen, das ist mit Clan. Wie schwer ist es möglich herauszufinden, dass es sich um ein Spiel handelt in diesem Chat? Oder könnte ein Person aufgrund dessen in einen Raster fallen, dass er ein Terrorist sein könnte, wenn über Co-Ordinaten gesprochen wird, die man angreifen würde, oder ähnliches.
Ich versuche mal deine Frage zu übersetzen. Was ich richtig verstanden habe, ist, du spielst sagen wir nur das Beispiel wegen Counter-Strike und da hältst du dich in einem Chat darüber, da hinten in der Haus-Ecke steht einer, schießt ihn mal bitte in den Kopf. Und deine Frage ist, ob jemand sozusagen, der das automatisch analysiert, unterscheiden kann, ob du da über ein Spiel sprichst oder ob du gerade wirklich jemand in den Kopf schießen willst? Aha, okay, das ist die Frage. So, wir sind also bei zweideutigen Sachen angekommen. Also da hält sich jemand sozusagen über in den Kopf schießen und die Frage ist jetzt, kann das System unterscheiden, ob das zwischen einem Spiel ist oder nicht?
Also es ist natürlich für den, der die Systeme baut und der die Informationen haben will, ja die Frage stellt, von hohem Interesse, dass man diese Unterscheidung treffen kann. Man möchte ja diese sogenannten False Positives, also die Dinge, die angezeigt werden, obwohl sie gar keine echten Treffer sind, gar keine echten Signale sind.
Man möchte den Gamer nicht zum Attentäter machen.
Richtig, genau. Weil das würde ja auch bedeuten, wenn ich jemanden erkenne als einen potenziellen Attentäter, dann muss ich oder dann wird der Staat, der überwachende Himmel und Hölle in Bewegung setzen, um das zu verhindern, was natürlich auch ein sehr, sehr großer Aufwand ist. Und das ist zumindest meines Erachtens nicht von Interesse des Überwachenden. Man möchte ja eine Information haben, die korrekt ist.
Das ist schonmal ein Punkt, auf die Zunge zu gehen, man sagt, dem Staat ist nicht daran gelegen, niemanden falsch zu verdächtigen, sondern er schaut möglicherweise einfach nur den Aufwand.
Du musst die Kosten sehen.
Das sehe ich gerade, genau. So, also das heißt, er ist daran interessiert. Aber ist es dann auch umsitzbar?
Das ist sicherlich auch wieder endlich. Also was sicherlich niemanden beruhigen wird, ist, dass natürlich auch Chats in Computerspielen überwacht werden und möglicherweise sogar mit der Argumentation, naja, das wird benutzt, um Terroristen auszubilden. Das klingt erst mal ein bisschen absurd, bis man herausfindet, dass die Armeen tatsächlich ihre Soldaten an ähnlichen Software trainieren. Also warum soll man nicht auch Häuserkampf und irgendwie sich gegenseitig Deckung in einem Computerspiel trainieren, wenn man irgendwie in Anführungszeichen Terroristen ausbildet? Das Einzige, was einen schützt, ist, dass es so viele Counter-Strike-Spieler gibt, dass man schon irgendwie noch weitere Kriterien braucht, um jemanden wirklich verdächtigen zu können.
Wir haben ja vorhin auch gehört, dass es nicht nur ein Signal gibt, woraufhin eine Entscheidung getroffen wird. Es gibt Hunderte, wenn nicht Tausende. Es gibt viele Algorithmen, die arbeiten mit Zehntausenden von sogenannten Features. Diese Features können ganz einfache Informationen sein. Spielt diese Person Counter-Strike, ja oder nein? Es ist höchst unwahrscheinlich, dass ein Algorithmus eine Entscheidung trifft nur auf der Basis eines solchen Features.
Um ein einfaches Beispiel zu bringen, möglicherweise bringe ich den Algorithmus bei, wenn jemand im Kopf schließt, dann guckt doch mal bitte, ob von derselben IP-Adresse auf einen Counter-Strike-Server zugegriffen wird. Wenn ja, dann ist er vielleicht erst mal raus.
Also nicht konkret so, aber so kann man sich das zumindest vorstellen. Da kommen dann vielleicht noch Sachen dazu, wie macht öfter mal in Afghanistan Urlaub oder was man sonst noch so tun kann, was vielleicht für sich genommen erst mal unverdächtig ist, aber wenn drei, vier, fünf von diesen Faktoren zusammenkommen. Wobei das natürlich auch immer alles Bilder sind, die in den Köpfen der Leute stattfinden, die diese Systeme programmieren, also ihre Vorurteile und Projektion, Narrative quasi darüber, was ein Terrorist ist, projizieren auf diese Daten, um da wieder verdächtig herauszuziehen.
Also um Marius Frage jetzt abschließend zu beantworten, kann man sagen, also im Prinzip haben die Leute, die überwachen, da relativ wahrscheinlich Interesse dran. Man kann es aber nicht genau sagen, ob es ihnen immer gelingt. Also ihr müsst jetzt noch mal sagen, ob das stimmt oder nicht. Ich versuche nur zusammenfassen, was sie sagen. Okay, Mario, dann ist deine Frage beantwortet.
Ja, ich hätte auch noch eine, wenn...
Ich würde jetzt lieber Schluss machen, weil wir sagen, noch eine große konditionierte Konsequenz zu sprechen, nämlich wie wir zu diesem ganzen Zock umgehen. Aber du kannst sie gerne auf chaosradio.ccc.de stellen. Da gibt es einen Blog zur Sendung und vielleicht kann man sie noch beantworten. In dem Fall, was natürlich spannend ist bei Mario, ich fange ja immer sofort an auszudenken, wenn jemand sagt, ja, da sind verschiedene Datenpunkte, die zusammenkommen. Ich meine, er ist halt anscheinend sozusagen jemand aus Deutschland, der in den USA ist. Also und dann noch so Killerspiele. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht gefährlich ist. So, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit…
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich Sorgen machen.
Okay, nein. Nicht, wenn alles gut geht, das ist ja, da sind wir bei dem Punkt genau. Jetzt zum Schluss noch, Joachim, du hast mal sozusagen davon gesprochen, dass das eigentliche Problem nicht so sehr in den Algorithmen oder Technik ist, die da angewendet werden, sondern in der Art und Weise, wie das Ganze verwendet wird. Was wäre denn sozusagen eine Wunschvorstellung, wie das Ganze ablaufen könnte? Also was wäre denn etwas, wo man dann sagen muss, okay, dann müssen wir keine Sorgen mehr machen?
Lass mich so anfangen. Zur Wunschvorstellung komme ich am Schluss. Also ich finde, dieses ganze Skandalon des Snowden-Skandals, das wurde von vielen Medien und auch von vielen Leuten in der Netzgemeinde so geflamed, dass jetzt die Privatheit abgeschafft wäre und wir müssten jetzt über das Private neu reden und so weiter. Und ich finde eigentlich geht es genau in die falsche Richtung. Wir müssen eigentlich mehr über das Geheime reden. Wir müssen eigentlich darüber reden, was geheim ist in dieser Gesellschaft und was wir als geheim akzeptieren in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft und was nicht. Also ist es legitim zu sagen, es gibt Dinge, die werden nur in zehn oder werden nur ganz wenigen Parlamentariern in einem Gezählengremium sozusagen dargelegt mit Rückfragemöglichkeiten und sonst darf das keiner wissen.
Also um es konkret zu machen, zu sagen, du redest jetzt davon, dass diese Geheimdienste, die diese ganze Überwachung veranstalten, auch von irgendjemanden kontrolliert werden?
Ja und wir wissen nicht, nach welcher Logik sie funktionieren, weil eben die Logik der Geheimdienste ist eben etwas, das aus ihrer Logik heraus schützenswert ist, geschützt werden muss. Deswegen ist natürlich Snowden auch das große, was ganz schlimm ist für die, weil er deren Logik veröffentlicht hat. Und wir müssen glaube ich darüber reden, also wie viel Geheimhaltung können wir akzeptieren? Wo ist Geheimhaltung sinnvoll, wo ist sie nicht sinnvoll? Und ich finde darüber wird viel zu wenig gesprochen.
Aber also heißt es zu sagen, heißt es umgedreht, dass du schon sagst, okay, damit das alles, was wir im Netz machen, irgendwie analysiert wird, damit müssen wir einfach leben. Und wir brauchen jetzt sozusagen eine gesellschaftliche oder politische Regelung, wie die Leute damit umgehen. Vor allen Dingen die Leute, die eigentlich dafür bezahlt werden, uns zur schützen vor Gefahren.
Nein, ich finde, wir müssen gar nicht damit leben, dass alles analysiert wird, was wir tun. Ich finde, wir müssen das einfach regeln und wir müssen es bestrafen, wenn jemand gegen diese Regeln verströst. Also ich glaube, sonst geht man Rechtsstaat auf.
Ich glaube, man muss auch ganz grundsätzlich das Konzept Geheimdienst infrage stellen an der Stelle. Es ist ja so, dass trotz dieser ganzen Überwachung, trotz dieser milliardenteuren Technik, zum Beispiel die NSA einfach nicht mitbekommen hat, dass da gerade in Nordafrika eine Revolution losgegangen ist. Als das da losging in Tunesien, das haben die erfahren, haltet euch fest, auf Twitter. Die geschätzte 90% der Erkenntnisse, der Geheimdienste, wenn nicht mehr, kommen aus öffentlichen Quellen. Also sogenannte Open-Source-Intelligence, OSINT ist der Fachbegriff bei denen. Die lesen einfach die Zeitung, wie jeder andere Mensch auch. Und natürlich braucht man, also wenn man sich jetzt mal in die Rolle eines Staates hineinversetzt, muss man wissen, was auf der Welt passiert, zweifels ohne. Aber es ist viel, viel sinnvoller, da einfach Leute einzustellen, die sich mit den verschiedenen Kulturen beschäftigt haben, die die Sprachen sprechen, die irgendwie wissen, was da losgeht, die da korrespondieren, hier vielleicht auch leben, die Zeitungen da lesen und diese Informationen einfach sinnvoll aufzubereiten, um gesellschaftliche Strömungen zu erkennen und das in, also das, was Intelligenz genannt wird, umzusetzen, nämlich eine Information für eine Regierung, die dazu führt, dass man sinnvoll auf der Basisentscheidung treffen kann. Dazu braucht man diesen ganzen Schlapphutkram einfach nicht. Zu 90 Prozent kommt die interessante Information da eh nicht daher, sondern einfach dadurch, dass man Leute fürs Denken bezahlt.
Das heißt sozusagen, die komplette Lösung ist politisch, die wir sozusagen anstreben. Das heißt aber auch, also Worst-Case-Szenarien, die machen einfach so weiter wie bisher, nur sozusagen, dass wir noch weniger davon mitkriegen. Es gibt bei der ganzen Technologie, der Auswertungsalgorithmen, eigentlich keine Art und Weise, wie man sich dazuverlässig vorwähren kann. Weil selbst wenn wir alle Inhalte verschlüsseln, können diese ganzen Sachen auch über die Metadaten funktionieren, wie wir heute auch gelernt haben, wieder gelernt haben.
Ja, also natürlich kann man auch versuchen, Metadaten zu verschleiern, indem man zum Beispiel regelmäßig sein Telefon mit seinen Freunden tauscht. Da gibt es eine Geschichte über einen Sprengstoff-Experten, der Hamas, der irgendwann seinen Kopf verloren hat, weil sein Telefon explodiert ist. Und da gab es so einen Onkel, der hat dann mal ein Geschenk bekommen. Und es war bekannt, dass der also regelmäßig seine Telefone tauscht und einfach rein statistisch irgendwann dieses Telefon in der Hand haben wird. Und dann haben sie einfach bloß diese eine Nummer überwacht und gewartet, bis er dran war und dann auf den Knopf gedrückt und dann sind irgendwie ihre Ohren geflogen. Also auch das hat seine Grenzen mit dem regelmäßig Telefonen tauschen. Technisch ist das Problem nicht zu lösen. Man kann den Leuten das Leben schwer machen. Man kann anfangen, alles zu verschlüsseln. Das ist auch das, was gerade passiert, dass viele Firmen ihre Webseiten komplett verschlüsseln, dass wenigstens dieses irgendwie auf den Knopfdruck alle Inhalte auswerten weggeht. Aber letzten Endes kann die Lösung eine politische Lösung sein.
Jetzt noch die Frage an euch beide, Joachim und Simon, ihr arbeitet ja an diesen Sachen. Der eine sagen wissenschaftlich, der andere sagen praktisch mit den Händen. Das fühlst du schon wieder in den Kopf, warum?
Ich finde, die Grenzen sind da glaube ich sehr fließend. Ich finde, total relevante Forschung findet außerhalb der Wissenschaft statt. Gleichzeitig sind wir ganz angewiesen auf solche Sachen, die er entwickelt hat. Die Grenzen sind da sehr fließend, finde ich.
Okay, die Frage an euch beide, was ihr an Erkenntnissen gewinnt oder an Maschinen baut, die so sagen, analysen können, kann natürlich dann auch wiederum gebraucht werden von Leuten, die diese Analysen machen, die wir eigentlich nicht wollen. Muss man sich mit dieser Frage auch beschäftigen, dass man da möglicherweise an Sachen mitbaut, die missbraucht werden können?
Also ganz ehrlich, bei mir überwiegt, dass die positiven Einsatzmöglichkeiten der Software, wir haben eigentlich ausschließlich über Negativsachen gesprochen, wo so eine Software eingesetzt wird. Es gibt aber, ich würde sagen, wesentlich mehr Einsatzgebiete, wo diese Dinge eingesetzt werden, um, ja ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, Gutes zu tun. Aber zum Beispiel kann man auch so einen Twitter-Stream analysieren, um bestimmte Entscheidungen zu treffen im Katastrophenschutz, in der Katastrophenhilfe. Wo werden gerade im Moment Sandsäcke benötigt? Diese Informationen kommen ganz, ganz oft über solche Social-Media-Kanäle und dahingehend gibt es auch sehr viel Forschung. Diese Daten müssen auch sehr, sehr schnell in sehr großen Mengen analysiert werden, um anderen Menschen zu helfen. Das heißt also nicht, dass wir diese Software nicht nur bauen, damit wir jemanden überwachen können. Das ist eigentlich eher so ein Seiteneffekt des Ganzen.
Wie ist es bei den Linguisten? Müssen sie sich auch mit sowas beschäftigen? Was sagen die dazu?
Klar, also ich sehe das aber ganz genauso. Ich sehe natürlich, dass bei Google natürlich Sachen in der Forschung passieren, die ganz weit vorne sind. Aber natürlich ist uns auch klar, dass von Google beispielsweise keine kritische Forschung zu erwarten ist im Sinne von wir zeigen auch, was nicht geht oder wo Probleme sind oder wir machen auch eine gesellschaftskritische Forschung oder sowas. Und ich finde, deswegen ist es auch wichtig, dass wir uns an Universitäten mit diesen Dingen kritisch auseinandersetzen und auch sozusagen weil wir die letzten sind, die auch tatsächlich unabhängig sagen können, funktioniert oder funktioniert nicht oder hier ist ein Einsatzbereich, der nicht favorisierbar ist. Also ich finde das ganz wichtig, dass man das tut. Und natürlich ist jede Algorithmenkritik auch dazu geeignet, Algorithmen besser zu machen. Aber davor ist man nicht gefeit.
Also meines Erachtens ist die Grenze da überschritten, wo die Forschung dann geheim gehalten wird. Also gerade im Bereich der Linguistik, gerade in Deutschland sind zehn Jahre Forschung passiert, die komplett in den Tresoren verschwunden sind, die komplett beim BND gelandet sind. Also es gibt das Gerücht, dass ein ernstzunehmender Teil der Analysekapazität der NSA technisch vom BND kommt, was Sprachanalyse angeht, und das wurde an deutschen Universitäten mit unseren Steuergeldern entwickelt und dann der Öffentlichkeit nicht zur Verfügung gestellt. Und das halte ich für ein großes Problem, Dual-Use wird man immer haben, egal welche Forschung man macht.
Was wird uns denn in Zukunft an Analysefähigkeiten noch erwarten? Gibt da so einen kleinen Blick in die Kristallkugel? Werden da noch vielleicht neue Sachen mit rein verknüpft, oder wird alles noch größer, schneller und schöner?
Auf jeden Fall, es wird auf jeden Fall größer, schneller und schöner. Das ist natürlich auch von Interesse für sehr viele Firmen, für sehr viele Menschen, die da auch sehr viel Kohle reinstecken können. Aber auch natürlich, wir wollen uns auch weiterentwickeln. Das ist natürlich für mich steht zumindest die technische Herausforderung hier im Vordergrund. Und ich glaube nicht, dass wir schon sehr weit aus der Steinzeit raus sind, was das betrifft.
Also ich freue mich schon sehr auf funktionierende automatische Übersetzungssysteme. Also Google Translate gibt einem so ein bisschen den Vorgeschmack davon, was alles gehen könnte, wenn es gut funktionieren würde. Ich denke, in zehn Jahren sind wir da einfach so weit. Und ich glaube, das wird schon Konsequenzen für das Leben auf dem Planeten haben, wenn die Sprachbarrieren einfach fallen zwischen den Menschen weltweit.
Ein Babelfisch in unserem Ohr. Joachim, du hast ja gesagt, man weiß ja mal nicht, was also schon was der Gesagte mit dem Text möglicherweise gemeint hat. Gibt es da sozusagen schon Forschungsansätze, dass man sagt, okay, dass man über Video und gesprochen Sprache und so, dass man vielleicht tatsächlich das, also Inhalt analysieren kann?
Also, man kann denke ich viel machen, das hängt einfach von unserem Begriff von Inhalt ab wiederum. Ich weiß, es tut mir leid, wenn ich da so ein bisschen rumwabere, aber ich glaube, die Entwicklung geht eher so dahin, dass man Gespräche, also komplexe Interaktionen, also wir gucken uns jetzt immer Texte an, aber eigentlich sind es ja Interaktionen, dass man da zunächst mal in die Breite geht, dass man ganze Diskurse, Debatten und ähnliches, die aufeinander bezogen sind, viel stärker mit in den Blick nimmt, aber natürlich auch gesprochene Sprache, dass man da auch weitere Daten mit einem Beziel als nur das gesprochene Wort automatisch verfügbar macht, sondern natürlich geschieht ja auch schon Blicke, Gesten und ähnliches, dass die systematisch lesbar werden. Solche Sachen, glaube ich, werden unser Verständnis von dem, wie gesellschaftliche Bedeutung im Gespräch produziert wird, revolutionieren.
Also und die Vorgehensweise ist dabei immer dieselbe, sagen wir. Man bringt dem Computer bei, bestimmte Teile unserer Kommunikation zu katalogisieren und dann sozusagen Relationen zwischen Einzelteilen herzustellen.
Also wenn wir auf dem Stand bleiben, auf dem wir sind ja, aber ich hoffe, die KI macht auch noch was.
Okay, das wäre dann möglicherweise ein anderes Chaosradio, das ich an dieser Stelle auch beschließen möchte. Vielen Dank an Anna Biselli, die hier noch bei uns war. Und auf Wiedersehen, Andreas Bogk.
Schönen guten Abend.
Simon Willnauer. Vielen Dank. Und Joachim Scharloth.
Schönen Abend noch.
Das ist glaube ich das erste Chaosradio, das ich mir persönlich noch einmal anhören muss, weil es da ein paar erstaunliche Wendungen gab. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt. Könnt ihr die gerne loswerden. Ihr könnt zum Beispiel an chaosradio.ccc.de schreiben. Ihr könnt auf Fritz.de den Podcast hören. Der wird später auch nochmal auf chaosradio.ccc.de erscheinen. Und Simon, wollt ihr noch was sagen?
Ja, ich wollte nur nochmal verdeutlichen, dass egal, was man damit machen will, je mehr Daten, desto besser.
Ah ja, je mehr Daten, desto besser. Liebe Leute, ich verabschiede mich. Ich übergebe an Flo Heiler. Der wird euch im Night Flight mit Punk-Musik bewerfen. Und mir bleibt nur noch ein zu sagen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter. Lasst ihr nicht überwachen. Und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.